okay let's go for a dangerous ride
dangerous i have to abort this game
first sorry sorry seriously leftovers
now i can go for dangerous right but i
have no longer
i don't no longer see him
okay here we are dangerous right except
okay let's go
[Music]
okay e4 e6 okay sure
please don't take on d5 that would be
okay come on guys
what is it we guys i'm going to show you
there are different ways of playing
against the exchange
french oh they're trolling me
i'm going to show you that there are
different ways in which you can beat the
um exchange range exchange range never
happens in the real games
only i just wait for banter blitz
i think they've agreed to troll me with
this and i don't know why they decided
to all play the same line
there are so many different lines i'm
going to play 10 different systems
against
exchange french now just to show you
that it's possible
[Music]
i'll go b5 b5 is not a positional move
but uh i want to grab some space and
if i kick that knight from c3 far behind
far back
then it might be a position on the move
too uh it's all just a matter of
your interpretation
chess is wrong says i promise not to
play the exchange okay i'm gonna try to
find your challenge and accept it
[Music]
somebody says i like anish but not big
fan of his chess
it's better than saying that you are a
fan of my chest but just like me
honestly if i were to choose one of the
two i would go with that so that's cool
[Music]
what exactly about my chest you don't
like
what don't you like about matches
the way i play with my bishops a lot
do you recommend custom queenside in the
exchange range not yet not yet but few
games into the session i might
i recommend to play the c5 like the way
i played the first two games but i want
to show
that there are different options there
are different ways of playing
let me set a trap look
just showing off my trapping skills if
he takes i have bishop h2
a dirty little trick not sure knight d5
is good i'm not sure it's good
but i wanted to show off my tactic
tactical vision
too much luck here only me yeah i think
it's only you
i think it's only you
[Music]
97.7 is all good no
the level of 1800 to 200 is very common
to exchange variation you know what's
coming
you know why it's coming uh because i uh
because my
uh wife madame
uh
madame is uh recommended it on her
series on just 24 that's why it's
popular
there's no other reason and um
[Music]
oh i'm stuck so well here guys
it's such a beautiful position i'm
simply feeling dizzy from the beauty of
it
oh my god i have knight a5 take c4 take
f3 take e3 take [ __ ] could you
check such a good position guys
good lord good lord he should take on d5
with the bishop
oh he doesn't oh he doesn't oh my god
this is
such a such destruction here
93 for example check this is a very
dangerous ride for free
check well
whoa takes maybe also rookie 6 rook g6
was possible
but i'm just grabbing them pawns
i think here is this chat yeah i
probably do
probably do
[Music]
nice youtube channel unleash thank you
each unless 27 after queen wise queen g4
um i think i know what you mean but no i
went for the main line i think all this
uh
27 business is uh
okay he presented before quinnish
teammate but all this queen the sound
business i know what to talk about in
the main we never
it's uh if you look at it with the
modern entrances there
it has some it has some um there is a
point to it obviously but it's not uh
okay boys and girls okay
wait i don't know who accepted i
accepted no one wait
uh again oh sorry sir that's not that's
not a premium sorry sorry
let's not do the premium commercial once
again yeah but uh do
go premium guys go premium
how much does it even cost not so much
not so much